reading oh gosh I think it's terrifying
I have no experience about alright five
seconds move when I say go plant your
feet you go hon - I got a dude right
hand my experience of boxing is very
limited CJ's gonna make sure that none
of this gets destroyed I don't want to
mess this up
my your feet jab cross jab cross ha ha
ha I got my ass kicked in Pilates so
this is gonna be challenging as well I
really hope I don't pass out five hot ok
I've been boxing since I was a little
kid a lot of people come in a box saying
already in shape the way you breathe the
way you you push yourself is a lot
different than in any other sport boxing
really does push you to different levels
when you get into some technical drills
on how to move where to punch what punch
is what then we'll get into padwar
drills you guys are gonna hit some pads
so yeah I want to be pounding a piece of
meat right now grab like two levers here
pulls lovers right in front you okay now
I'm gonna take my left foot slide it
right out in front now the first point
is our jab the most important punch in
boxing the jab is gonna be our lead
hands going to come out and rotate over
these to hurt what we're hitting these
two knuckles hurt us we're just gonna
bring it and come right back keep our
legs bent the whole time ready one two
three four all right so now we're we go
to the cross across is the money punch
it's gonna come right from this how
you're gonna push off your back leg it's
gonna come straight a line from your
knee to your foot and come right back it
set across in this way I don't want you
punching somebody's cousin uncle sister
right punch the person right in funny
ready three four
much better five you see how now it gets
that snap okay so in boxing there's
numbers associated with punching a jab
isn't one across the two two one one two
jab
ah non-stop for the next 30 seconds this
right here let's go 3 3 3 3 3 there you
go
time alright so now we're work on how to
move our feet is everybody else up this
puddle resetting resetting reset good
continuously let your weight feel in
your legs and go backwards I feel like I
could sneak up on someone and really
give him the hammer I don't even think
we're through the warm-up and I'm like
already tired when the Bell beeps it's
gonna give us a 30-second warning so
you're gonna go non-stop on the bag it's
not about pushing it it's just about
non-stop movement 1 2 3 4 yep
one two three four jab jab jab cross jab
cross back up look at it look at that
out nah stop go
we got a strong jab and a strong cross
but we'll see what the guys have whatnot
push that you hit with stop there you
set it off again again again Jeff Ross
second
punch it lugar their ad they all
actually have a good good um a good
punch on him but hers actually has more
populist yeah
hala gonna beat their absolute just
watch out arms are turning into noodles
so it's uh it's challenging to different
than Pilates it's okay
fine everybody can handle it grab your
jump rope are you ready right you're
fast feet go fast me hands up fast feet
speed speed and push-ups go push up from
the put your additional going mountain
climb oh let's go let's go just go three
two one time I'm thoroughly beat my feet
hurt too there's not anything like it
really though I mean like it's cool you
guys you guys you guys did really well
for your first class can you say that
one more time please to the camera yes
who did really well you know it teaches
you how to push through things when
you're tired it teaches you how to
achieve goals that you didn't know what
were possible
boxing is just it's not good just for
physical fitness but just understanding
how much more about yourself you can
learn